[Applause]
growing defiance
a consecutive sunday of historic
protests calling for their leader to go
standing firm despite threats of a new
crackdown
they want fair elections not what they
see as the fast that happened two weeks
ago
[Applause]
i think that everyone here on the square
is afraid and there is a reason to be
scared
because our government has already shown
how it can treat its people
but there is faith more faith and fear
so that's why we came here today
but president alexander lukashenko is
standing firm
too in the face of this challenge his
military
for the first time saying they'll guard
certain sites from protesters not the
police
a potentially sinister sign the way i
read the
most recent speech of the defense
minister is
as a uh a preparation
of his subordinates uh to be used
against uh what they would see as
domestic enemies which of course are our
own peaceful citizens
so martial law or something like it
would be a next major escalation on the
part of the authorities
[Applause]
and yet the sea of white and red flows
on
[Applause]
the baltic states linked arms 31 years
ago
in peaceful protest against soviet rule
it was a historic
milestone on their road to independence
and they believe history is being made
again
this time in belarus that's why tens of
thousands of people here in lithuania
have come together to reenact that human
chain
stretching from here close to the border
all the way to the capital vilnius
under pressure belarus's president has
even accused lithuania
and other nato allies of posing a threat
this is not not tanks nothing to do with
militaries
peaceful people with blacks flowers same
people
away on the streets of minsk carrying
flowers so
this rhetoric i would explain just for
domestic use
[Applause]
but back in belarus will people power
alone be enough to topple the regime
or will the president again use force
to beat back this call for change debra
haynes sky news vilnius